si raúl o buenos días participó de esta
sesión que fue a puerta cerrada lo hizo
a través de videoconferencia como ya es
habitual y se podría resumir en cinco
puntos lo que pidió a los países más
poderosos del mundo lo primero recordó
los bombardeos del domingo en kiev que
justamente llegaron en la previa en la
antesala de esta cumbre del g7 e hizo un
resumen de lo que está viviendo este
país a diario normalmente este país
recibe 15 misiles desde rusia pero ese
día el domingo hubo 62 y en general en
estos 4 meses el país ha sido
bombardeado por 3 mil 800 misiles luego
pidió como tú decías armas garantías de
seguridad aunque reconoció que es un
tema que se va a tratar más a fondo de
la cumbre de la otan que comienza mañana
en madrid también pidió seguridad
alimentaria recordemos que este país es
conocido como el granero del mundo que
actualmente hay 22 millones de toneladas
de granos que son que están bloqueados
en ucrania que no pueden salir al resto
del mundo la onu está tratando de
sacarlos pero también pidió espacio para
almacenar las nuevas cosechas pidió que
les ayude justamente los países a lograr
espacio para poder
guardar esos granos también intensificar
las sanciones qué es lo que estaría
aparentemente acordando este eje 7 más
sanciones en contra de rusia de este
país para que no pueda hacer la guerra y
finalmente ayuda para la reconstrucción
que algunos calculan en 600.000 millones
de dólares pero en general también raúl
lanzó una suerte de línea roja y es que
dijo que para él lo ideal sería que la
guerra se acabe antes de fin de año
porque llega el invierno y eso va a ser
aún más difícil para las tropas para
mantenerse en pie va a prolongar
finalmente este conflicto
erika también me oye que 7 recibe con
invitados a cinco naciones emergentes
entre ellas argentina que va a ser el
gobierno argentino durante esta cumbre
del g7 para que fueron invitados a esos
países
si son países emergentes muy importantes
indonesia argentina sudáfrica india y
senegal raúl son países que el g7
prefiere tener de su lado por decirlo de
alguna manera porque son grandes
productores de energía y de alimentos
también tienen buenos recursos naturales
no ciertos que podrían ayudar a superar
las crisis derivadas justamente de la
guerra en ucrania argentina
concretamente tiene no cierto muchos
recursos energéticos y también es un
gran productor de cereales para todo el
mundo hola soy el canciller alemán lo
dijo esta mañana no caigamos en la
trampa de rusia que quiere hacer creer
al mundo que estamos divididos entre las
potencias occidentales globales y el
resto del mundo las consecuencias del
hambre de los precios de las energías de
la inflación la está sufriendo dijo el
todo el mundo y la democracia está en
todo el mundo mantengamos unidos así que
ya se sacaron las fotos de familia están
teniendo en este momento una reunión van
a almorzar juntos y se irán al final de
esta jornada